[Music]
in today's hustle and bustle world it's
not uncommon to forgo brown bagging it
and instead to grab a meal on the go
it's not surprising to see that food
retailers from mega supermarkets to tiny
convenience stores carry pre-packaged
sandwiches for the hungry in a hurry
customer
[Music]
ham and cheese
cheese and tomato
chicken salad just a few of the many
sandwich varieties you can buy
ready-made retail customers specify
which ingredients they want in their
sandwich order and the factory sets up
the assembly lines accordingly the first
step is to load fresh bread into an
automated machine
while doing so they visually inspect the
slices and remove any with holes or
other flaws
the machine separates the slices in the
loaf then because this sandwich requires
it an internal roller spreads melted
butter
the machine then drops the buttered
slices face up onto the belt that moves
through the production line where first
an automated depositor squirts on the
quantity and type of mayonnaise the
customer requested
workers manually lay on the more
specific ingredients such as cold cuts
or grated cheddar cheese
in the prep area workers load logs of
ham into a slicer
the customer has specified the size and
weight of the slices it wants in the
sandwich and the factory programs the
slicer accordingly
the slices go off to the assembly line
where workers add them to the sandwiches
next they close up the sandwiches
they stack the sandwiches in piles of
two
the belt then brings the sandwiches to a
mechanized cutter
the cutter works like a reciprocating
saw
the vertical blade oscillating at high
speed as the sandwich travels through it
the stacked halves on each side will be
packaged together as one sandwich
some of the sandwich varieties produced
in largest quantities are made on a
fully automated assembly line
a robot suctions up bread slices and
places them on a moving belt
positioning plates descend and adjust
the slices so that they'll be perfectly
centered under the nozzles which
dispense the sandwich ingredients
production here egg salad sandwiches
a nozzle deposits a set quantity of
chopped egg with mayonnaise on every
second slice
at the next station robotic arms lined
with suction cups grab the empty slices
and flip them over onto the filled
slices
next stop an ultrasonic knife
it slices the sandwiches in two using
vibrations produced by high frequency
sound waves
this cutting method gives a cleaner edge
next robotic arms pick up half of each
sandwich spin it around and stack it
onto the other half
a robot grabs four finished sandwiches
at a time and puts them in triangular
plastic trays
which then move on to the ceiling and
labeling stations
back on the semi-automated assembly line
workers stack the sandwiches manually
and place them in individual plastic
line cardboard packages
a conveyor belt brings them to a machine
which pushes down the top flap and heat
seals it shut
the sandwiches hit store shelves within
12 hours of production
they stay fresh for an additional three
days after which the sandwich company
removes the unsold ones while making its
daily delivery of new ones
you